[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au programme de l'actualité des
infos pratiques et des idées de sortie
voici le programme de ce 7 février
plus de 5000 personnes sont décédant le
séisme qui a frappé la Turquie et la
Syrie et lundi depuis la solidarité
s'organise et notamment dans les
Yvelines des pompiers du département
sont partis et prêter main forte
secouriste locaux et des appels au don
sont également lancés on en parle devant
nos informations du jour elle aussi
cette actualité cette nouvelle journée
de mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites la boutique est située dans
une galerie commerciale d'un hypermarché
au milieu d'enseignes de prêt-à-porter
depuis novembre le relais Val de Seine a
ouvert un neuvième magasin c'est un
plaisir c'est une friperie solidaire on
y trouve des vêtements de seconde main à
des prix réduits l'entreprise
d'insertion collabore avec des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi pour se faire
inviter Émilie Morand qui est directrice
du releval de Seine
et puis il y a 25 ans par essais le tout
premier tome des aventures d'Harry
Potter le célèbre sorcier créé par j.k
Rowling et devenu par la suite un
véritable phénomène de société son
anniversaire a été à célébré dans
plusieurs librairies de France le
week-end dernier à l'occasion des nuits
des livres Harry Potter des dizaines de
fans se sont rassemblés notamment au
pavé dans la marée et en cours reportage
et ce sera dans notre partie culture
tout à l'heure avec des invités il y
aura notamment l'humoriste belge Manon
lepomme qui sera avec nous par
visio-conférence je vais beaucoup mieux
merci c'est le nom de son one woman show
quel jouera sur la scène de la Royal
Factory à Versailles du 16 au 18 février
prochain avec nous également plateau
Mickael Diony bonsoir alors vous êtes
vous artiste musical originaire des
Yvelines et vous avez sorti en 2022
c'était tout récemment votre dernier EP
qui est se nomme 18 quelques mots sur
vous sur votre univers quelle est-il
l'univers Michael Yoni et aussi sur
l'esprit de cette paix alors c'est un
album pop rock avec une tendance électro
et je chante j'écris en français voilà
c'est un univers assez romanesque avec
une mélancolie heureuse et on en dira un
peu plus tout à l'heure alors je le
disais dans les titres également on va
parler du relais Val-de-Seine qui a
ouvert une nouvelle boutique du côté de
plaisir et c'est avec vous Emilie Morand
bonsoir vous êtes directrice a du relais
Val de Seine alors c'est une entreprise
d'insertion qui travaille avec des
personnes éloignées de l'emploi quels
sont les missions de relevage de scène
alors effectivement on est une
entreprise d'insertion on collecte on
valorise les textiles qui sont données
par les particuliers et tout ça pour
créer de l'emploi et redonner une
seconde vie aux vêtements on parlera de
toutes ces thématiques tout à l'heure
également dans cette émission à suivre
bien sûr les informations du jour ou
proposera notamment une balade urbaine
autour de la gare de La Verrière c'est
là que va se construire dans les
prochaines années le Eco quartier
l'echoquartiers le futur écoquartier est
de garbecane c'est un projet d'envergure
pour la ville et comme chaque mardi il y
aura aussi les insolites de Véronique
ithurby dans les informations qui vous
ont peut-être échappé ces derniers jours
dans les Yvelines et puis comme
d'habitude aussi votre astuce du chef
pour briller en cuisine ce soir c'est
Armindo Machado qui va vous donner sa
recette des noix de Saint-Jacques à la
provençale ça vous donne envie peut-être
en plateau
vous savez peut-être cuisiner notre
Saint-Jacques en moi j'ai toujours du
mal à la cuisiner c'est toujours assez
difficile on en parlera tout à l'heure
mais avant de débuter tout cela on va
jeter un petit coup d'œil à la météo de
demain
[Musique]
et c'est une journée de mercredi assez
similaire par rapport à aujourd'hui avec
du froid mais aussi du soleil le matin
il fera moins de degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et à Rambouillet - 1
degré du côté doux dans et Versailles
dans l'après-midi même condition avec un
thermomètre qui grimpe quelque peu
compter 6 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et 5
degrés sur le reste du département ce
mercredi à 8 février nous fêterons les
jacquelines
comme chaque jour dans le 7 8 le point
sur les informations du jour ce qu'il
faut retenir de l'actualité bino c'est
avec Michael et demi d'euros
on commence ces informations du jour par
cette tragédie survenue ce lundi en
Turquie et en Syrie un séisme d'une
magnitude 7,8 et des répliques ont
frappé ces deux pays au moins 5000
personnes sont mortes d'après les
dernières estimations dans les Yvelines
très sapeurs-pompiers se rendent sur
place pour aider la population avec
notamment un médecin une infirmière et
un chien de recherche il rejoignent le
détachement usar spécialisé dans le
sauvetage et le déblayement la
solidarité s'organise également dans le
département le Secours populaire des
Yvelines débloque une première somme de
5000 euros et lance un appel au don pour
pousser à la solidarité au soutien
financier pour les victimes de la
catastrophe sur le plan national 100.000
euros de fond d'urgence ont été
débloqués pour les familles pour donner
les dons peuvent se faire en ligne sur
le site officiel du Secours populaire
après les journées du 19 et 31 janvier
un nouveau mouvement de greffe contre la
réforme des retraites était organisées
ce mardi 7 février dans toute la France
selon les organisations syndicales à
mobilisation est toujours aussi forte 17
buts CGT sont partis aujourd'hui depuis
les Yvelines certains depuis trappes une
mobilisation qui a eu des conséquences
sur les transports avec intrins sur deux
pour le RER A ou encore un train sur 3
pour le RER BC des chiffres similaires
pour les trains sur la ligne jlnu du
côté de l'enseignement les chiffres sont
en baisse selon l'académie de Versailles
dans le premier degré on est passé de
41% de grévistes le 19 janvier à 11,43%
ce mardi 7 février au collège on recense
15,43% d'enseignants en grève et 9,42
dans les lycées l'association
protectrice des animaux la SPA lance une
application éphémère pour trouver son
futur compagnon pendant la période de la
Saint-Valentin le concept une fois
l'application téléchargée 5 questions
seront posées à l'internaute pour mieux
le connaître ainsi identifie l'animal
qui le correspond le mieux le refuge le
plus proche pour rencontrer des
pensionnaires lui Seraing ainsi suggérés
trois refuges sont ouverts dans les
Yvelines Orgeval Hermeray et à plaisir
le Paris Saint-Germain qui déménagera
l'été prochain son d'entraînement à
Poissy pourraient également changer de
stats selon nos confrères de l'équipe le
PSG à mandaté un intermédiaire pour
l'aider à trouver un site pour la
construction d'un nouveau stade dans la
région il s'agirait de la société
Legends une entreprise qui a déjà
travaillé dans le football avec le Real
Madrid et Manchester City les
propriétaires Cateri voudraient toujours
un stade une capacité de 60 000
personnes il y a quelques jours le
député de la 12e circonscription des
Yvelines carlive avait suggéré de
construire un stade à Poissy mais si et
Neymar joueront-ils dans les Yvelines
réponse dans les prochaines semaines
et si vous aussi près de chez vous vous
êtes témoin d'une information ou d'un
fait qui vous fait réagir n'hésitez pas
à le partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news
et avec nous toujours en plateau Emily
Morhange le disait directrice du relais
Val de Seine et on parle avec vous de
cette 9e boutique qui a ouvert du côté
de plaisir c'est dans la galerie eau
shopping alors c'est le cas depuis
novembre elle a ouvert depuis novembre
mais l'inauguration officielle c'était
vendredi dernier c'est une friperie
solidaire en commençant parlé on y
trouve des vêtements de seconde main à
des prix réduits et vous êtes donc une
entreprise d'insertion qui est collabore
avec des personnes éloignées de l'emploi
pour la boutique c'est la deuxième qui
ouvre à 50 ans en Yvelines il y en avait
déjà une à Maurepas pourquoi l'ouvrir à
plaisir cette fois-ci
alors effectivement nous étendons notre
réseau de boutiques le relais sur notre
secteur donc à savoir les Yvelines
notamment on a souhaité pouvoir proposer
cette offre-là aux personnes habitant
plus au sud du département puisque nos
autres boutiques sont plutôt au nord et
on a eu un accueil relativement même
très favorable
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
également pardon du bailleur Auchan qui
nous a
fait une proposition qui était
relativement intéressante pour nous pour
pouvoir intégrer une un centre
commercial donc c'était la notre
première implantation sur ces sur une
zone comme celle-là finalement ensuite
alors pour un magasin de vêtements de
seconde main on est au sein d'une
galerie commerciale et en plus vous êtes
situé entre des enseignes de
prêt-à-porter
en effet
[Musique]
il y avait une vraie volonté de
s'implanter dans ce genre de lieu là
vous le dites une implantation dans un
une galerie commerciale et puis ça
évolue aussi avec le temps c'est que il
y a quelques années on s'installer
plutôt en centre-ville aujourd'hui
via les politiques de responsabilité
sociétale et environnementale les
bailleurs ont tendance à aussi venir
nous chercher pour qu'on offre une autre
offre à leurs clients et donc ces
nouveaux pour nous c'est aussi nouveau
pour eux la seconde main se démocratise
et donc je pense que ça répond à une
offre assez globale et donc on répond
peut-être aussi à leurs clients qui sont
plus en recherche de type d'achat
ce qu'est le relais Val-de-Seine si vous
nous rejoignez dans cette émission et
que vous vous demandez justement ce que
c'est le relais Val-de-Seine son
président nous fait la présentation
c'est au micro de Mélanie poquet
[Musique]
on prend des gens qui avaient pas de
boulot pour une raison X ou Y on les
fait travailler dans notre entreprise on
les accompagne et à la sortie au bout
des deux ans ou avant on les a on leur a
permis de retrouver les codes de
fonctionnement d'une entreprise on les a
embrayés sur un parcours de formation
par exemple où on leur a trouvé un CDI
quelque part dans le dans la filière
dans laquelle ils avaient envie de
travailler
[Musique]
c'est juste un prétexte il y a un
gisement terrible en France qui est que
chaque Français nous jetons chacun
peut-être je jette moins aujourd'hui
parce que je donne au relais mais voilà
mais avant de connaître le relais les
vêtements étaient donnés ou jetés on en
jette en moyenne 10 kg par an et par
habitant en France des chaussures et des
vêtements donc on a décidé d'utiliser ce
gisement textile donc de collecter de
trier et de revendre pour permettre de
donner du travail aux gens en insertion
qui sont chez nous
[Musique]
il y a même un atelier qu'on vient de
créer qui s'appelle r où là on va
recustomiser des choses donc là pour les
pour des jeunes ou moins jeunes qui
cherchent vraiment des vêtements qui
n'existent pas parce qu'on en aura créé
5 donc voilà donc on va essayer de
du plus jeune au moins jeunes du celui
qui a plus de revenus à celui qui a
moins de revenus vous allez trouver tout
ce que vous voulez dans la boutique
[Musique]
on disait il y a un objectif d'insertion
on va en parler dans un instant mais
dans le contexte actuel l'inflation
galopante le réchauffement climatique
aussi qui nous pousse peut-être adopter
d'autres moyens de consommation le fait
de se tourner vers des vêtements de
seconde main aujourd'hui ça fait de plus
en plus sens évidemment comme je le
disais
il y a une attente sur différents sujets
sur une accessibilité avec le prix
puisque aujourd'hui quand vous venez
dans une boutique Le Relais vous pouvez
acheter 5 vêtements adultes pour 15
euros mixte homme femme et vous pouvez
acheter 5 vêtements enfants pour 10
euros donc vous avez une offre qui est
complètement accessible donc
effectivement
pour les personnes orientées petit prix
mais il y a aussi des personnes qui
veulent un achat engagé ou les deux et
qui s'orientent dans nos magasins ou
plus généralement dans la friperie
solidaire puisqu'on fait partie du
mouvement Emmaüs et je profite qu'on
soit plusieurs en plateaux est-ce que
vous les vêtements de seconde main ça
vous intéresse ce que vous avez déjà
acheté des vêtements de seconde main
j'ai déjà donné au relais à plusieurs
fois merci
mais justement comment arrive-t-il dans
la boutique ses vêtements quel est le
cheminement avant alors le cheminement
pour arriver à la boutique il faut déjà
effectivement comme Michael que des
personnes donnent dans les bornes donc
toutes les bornes que vous pouvez voir
accessibles pour mettre ses vêtements
donc je les consignes dans un sac fermé
des vêtements des chaussures du linge de
maison et de la maroquinerie on va venir
collecter ses vêtements toutes les
semaines ensuite on vient les trier sur
notre centre de tri à
Chanteloup-les-Vignes et ensuite selon
leurs qualités ils vont trouver un
débouché différent et donc la qualité la
plus belle est adressée dans nos 9
magasins en
Île-de-France
donc dans les boutiques du relais avec
une démarche d'insertion le relais Val
de scène travaille avec ces personnes
qui sont éloignées de l'emploi quatre
personnes dans la boutique à plaisir et
on va écouter tout de suite d'ailleurs
le témoignage de Mohamed qui est
responsable adjoint de cette boutique à
Plaisir écoutez un moment une covid a
commencé
pas moyen de trouver un emploi la seule
possibilité ça a été le relais
et voilà j'en suis content avant d'être
vendeur j'étais médiateur social de
proximité 8 ans 8 ans de médiation
sociale
c'est une chance de leur donner voilà de
cette opportunité de rebondir peut-être
de se réinsérer de revenir dans une
démarche d'emploi alors c'est une chance
c'est eux qui pourrontière je dirais
c'est une opportunité d'être une
entreprise d'insertion et de pouvoir
proposer des emplois à des personnes qui
ont besoin d'un accompagnement avant un
retour à la vie
d'emplois plus classique et donc
l'accompagnement qu'on propose c'est
effectivement avoir un emploi et un
accompagnement qui est suivi par un
chargé d'insertion professionnelle pour
lever les freins à l'embauche donc soit
des freins sociaux notamment liés au
logement des freins de mobilité et puis
ensuite de découvrir son projet
professionnel c'est clair pour certains
et ça prend plus de temps pour d'autres
la Mohamed ah pardon la Mohamed c'est
une personne qui a eu un parcours
d'insertion qui s'est fortement engagé
dans la vente et qui s'est vu du coup
proposer un emploi pérenne chez nous de
responsable adjoint pour pouvoir ensuite
accueillir d'autres personnes en
parcours d'insertion et transmettre
c'est compétences et savoir-faire il y a
une réussite d'ailleurs une fois qu'on
passe par le relais Val de Seine pour
repartir justement vers l'emploi donc on
a comme on a une entreprise d'insertion
on a on est conventionné avec la
Direction du Travail donc on a des
objectifs à atteindre de minimum 70% de
ce qu'on appelle une sortie positive
donc ce sont des personnes qui vont
retrouver soit une formation qualifiante
soit un emploi à l'issue et donc on a
atteint nos objectifs sur 2022 et on
travaille encore à les faire progresser
pour l'année à venir sur place on
retrouve du textile dans cette boutique
il y en a pour tout le monde c'est
finalement comme dans une boutique
traditionnelle on va dire homme femme
enfant c'est ça homme femme enfant de la
maroquinerie et puis une nouvelle offre
d'uby donc on avec des vêtements qui
auraient dû être recyclés qui étaient
trop abîmée on est en recréé une
nouvelle collection et donc ça c'est la
nouveauté de 2022 puisqu'on a créé 10
nouveaux emplois sur le dernier
trimestre 2022 et donc on a une offre
dans toutes nos boutiques d'offres
upside clé sur des collections
thématiques mensuelles et vous parliez
des tarifs alors j'ai lu chez nos
confrères du Parisien par exemple une
veste d'une très bonne marque italienne
était proposée par exemple à plaisir à
euros contre 800 euros dans le commerce
au prix neuf il y a différents types de
tarifs alors il y a différents types
donc effectivement là c'est
effectivement l'exemple un peu suprême
en fait dire c'est que les prix fixés
sont en théorie un quart du prix du neuf
et ensuite pour les vêtements
plus basiques on va avoir comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure une offre
accessible en loup de 5 Pièces pour 15
euros sur les pièces adultes et vous
pouvez mixer femme et homme et pour les
pièces enfants du coup c'est 5 Pièces
pour 10 euros au-delà naissance jusqu'à
12 ans et donc pour prendre récolter ses
vêtements comme Michael l'appel à passer
au téléspectateurs c'est de donner ses
vêtements de les donner dans dans les
boîtes dont vous y référence c'est ces
box c'est ça donc de faire le tri sur ce
qu'on utilise pas parce qu'il y a
beaucoup ça de ce qu'on utilise pas et
donc de donner une chance à des
personnes en donnant ses vêtements c'est
en fait faire un geste pour créer de
l'emploi et donc effectivement on vous
incite à faire ce geste et premier bilan
puis l'ouverture depuis octobre depuis
novembre est-ce que ça ça marche cette
boutique à plaisir alors c'est une
boutique effectivement qui est en
démarrage donc qui doit trouver son son
rythme classique disons
et donc effectivement c'est une boutique
qui fonctionne bien qui a un flux et les
clients découvrent cette nouvelle offre
et c'est une nouvelle clientèle pour
nous donc on travaille à s'améliorer
toujours et quels sont les projets pour
2023 du coup alors les projets
on cherche à se développer à s'agrandir
et pour ça il nous faut davantage de
textile pour créer toujours davantage
d'emploi donc on sait que
chaque citoyen
achètent près de 10 kg par an et par
habitant et donc en jette ou en redonne
quasi autant et donc dans les Yvelines
on est ou même en Île-de-France en
général on est à peine trois kilos par
an et par habitant donc en fait on peut
encore progresser dans le gestes de
teuteries merci Emilie Morand d'être
venu en parler en plateau salut vous
êtes la directrice du relais Val de
Seine on va poursuivre ses actualités
avec une balade pour mieux comprendre
l'avenir du futur EcoQuartier et
garbecane c'est à La Verrière samedi
dernier les habitants étaient conviés à
venir découvrir et échanger autour des
travaux d'envergure pour ce projet qui
devrait démarrer ses travaux en 2025
1500 logements sont prévus sur place 60
000 mètres carrés également de Paul
d'activités économique on va faire la
visite avec Julien Leroy et Mathilde de
Franco les verriers rois ont bravé le
froid et la pluie pour découvrir
l'évolution de leur ville une balade
urbaine était organisée dans le futur
EcoQuartier garbecane ce samedi 4
février au programme visite des
aménagements du secteur nord de la gare
et son futur parvis de 6000 mètres
carrés l'occasion aussi de parcourir les
terrains des bécanes situés de l'autre
côté de la voie ferrée ou de nombreuses
constructions verront le jour c'est un
moment de concertation c'est essentiel
pour parler avec les habitants de mieux
cerner leurs attentes de mieux prendre
en considération leur souhait donc
c'est in situ il y a rien de mieux
plutôt que une réunion dans une salle et
bien ça m'intéresse parce que j'aime
bien ma commune parce que j'y habite
depuis plus de 50 ans et ça me fait
plaisir de voir ce qui va maintenant
advenir de ce quartier et oui il faut un
café il faut quelques les choses qui qui
attirent les gens qui font que les gens
bougent 1500 logements et 60000 m² de
pôle d'activités économiques seront
créés dans ce futur quartier nouvelle
école maison médicale et près de 25
commerces feront partie des services
proposés l'occasion d'apporter un
nouveau souffle économique à la commune
la grande originalité de ce projet
urbain de cette requisition c'est de lui
donner un centre un centre-ville et
d'avoir une sorte de mutualisation de
service qui va permettre de donner de
l'attractivité globalement à la ville
grâce à ces constructions des bécanes on
va peut-être avoir une rénovation de
toute Orly Park puisque ça fait des
années qu'on se bat pour qu'il y ait une
réhabilitation extérieure surtout que ça
commence à être assez vétus des ateliers
de concertation seront organisés avec
les habitants suite à cette balade une
réunion publique en juin clôturera les
discussions permettant le début des
travaux dès 2025 il devrait durer une
quinzaine d'années
Émilie Michael je vous présente
Véronique qui nous a rejoint en plateau
comment ça va Véronique
pour cette émission aux intervenez un
petit peu plus tôt aujourd'hui parce que
comme chaque mardi vous nous parlez de
des insolites les insolites de Véronique
et c'est tout de suite dans le 7 8
les insolites de Véronique c'est à ces
informations qui vous ont peut-être
échappé dans le département des
informations qui sortent de l'ordinaire
c'est chaque mardi dans le 7 8 et on
commence Véronique avec ce qui est
peut-être moins un insolite plutôt on va
dire un coup de cœur aujourd'hui que
vous voulez nous faire partager c'est un
coup de cœur sur les
okonomiyaki ou les takoyakis je sais pas
si je prenais bien je sais pas si on
prononce le S final d'ailleurs moi non
plus on parle de street food à
Versailles
vous allez partir directement au fin
fond du Japon et pouvoir déguster de la
street food parce que c'est vraiment la
base sont pas des sushis ça rien à voir
et en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que
Vincent vicciola il est un amour du
Japon en amoureux de la cuisine c'est un
yvelinois il a il s'est offert un beau
voyage au Japon et il est allé surtout à
aux accueils Kyoto il a découvert cette
street food dont il raffole et il s'est
dit j'ai pas possible que je rentre en
France sans pouvoir les confectionner
moi-même puisque je n'en trouverai pas
ailleurs donc voilà il s'est dit faut
que j'apprenne à les faire donc il s'est
lié d'amitié avec un jeune chef japonais
qui avait un stand de rue qui
heureusement était anglophone et qui a
fini par lui lui donner ses recettes
parce qu'il faut des recettes très
précise évidemment des ingrédients aussi
bien précis et alors je peux vous dire
que takoyaki c'est en fait tacos ça veut
dire poulpe bien Kiss qui se cuit sur
plaque et économiyakis c'est force au
tofu cette espèce de grosse galette
blinis au chou avec de l'oeuf de la
levure soit du porte du tofu enfin bref
après non mais c'est vraiment super bon
c'est léger c'est des goûts qu'on
connaît pas donc c'est quand même je
trouve bien bien sympathique de pouvoir
découvrir une cuisine vraiment nouvelle
parce que ça c'est alors les gens qui se
passionnent pour le Japon qui sont allés
connaissent bien évidemment et ça leur
manque donc voilà la bonne adresse
Vincent vous accueille soit pour prendre
de la acheter de la nourriture à
emporter soit pour déguster sur place
donc il est au cœur de Versailles 63
avenue de Saint-Cloud et il y a aussi
des mots je suis glacés et puis petit à
petit va ouvrir la carte l'élargir un
petit peu il travaille sur les doriasis
qui sont comme vous le savez des
desserts ou haricots rouges
et dai Suki le nom de son restaurant ça
veut dire j'aime beaucoup où je t'aime
beaucoup alors là c'est une belle
transition pour la prochaine
la Saint-Valentin pour vous c'est une
fête commerciale ou ça vous tient à cœur
la Saint-Valentin nickel
bon en tout cas on peut la fêter de
manière insolite et le soir de la
Saint-Valentin si on veut de l'insolite
en tout cas il faut aller du côté de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye complètement il
faut même aller plus précisément au
musée Maurice Denis imaginez-vous parce
que il propose en fait de passer sa
Saint-Valentin de façon insolite
vraiment insolite en prenant des cours
de bachata qu'est-ce que c'est que la
bachata c'est une danse enfin vous savez
peut-être ça évoque tout de suite
l'Amérique latine ça vient de République
Dominicaine si ça il y a des influences
de meringuer de boléro de salsa enfin
alors c'est une danse qui est très
surtout réputée pour son côté sensuel
langoureux four ondulés voilà c'est
chaleureux c'est une bonne mise en
ambiance pour une soirée agréable de
Saint-Valentin éventuellement et donc
ils sont au musée je sais que vous en
parlerez mais bon il fallait quand même
prévenir les gens on a eu quelques
images de Mathilde de francoïs qui a
testé les cours de bachata on retrouvera
le reportage jeudi sur Facebook
mais bon moi je voulais quand même
prévenir les gens les téléspectateur
qu'il faut s'inscrire qui est pas 50000
places que ça dure donc deux heures j'ai
dit de 19 à 21h et donc écoutez vous
avez une semaine pour pour préparer vos
déhanchés et
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez du déchet
de Mathilde ça fait câble
non elle a ça dans le sang
depuis quelques années il me semble
voilà mais en tout cas c'était une
découverte pour elle mais on aura
l'occasion de découvrir avec elle
alors au-delà des informations sur vous
vous retrouvez aussi sur TV 78 pour
votre émission vyb qui donc mettons en
avant les personnalités yvelinoises de
ce territoire ce beau territoire des
Yvelines vous avez parlé de quoi
dernièrement et ce que vous en avez des
nouveaux prévu la prochaine dernièrement
j'ai parlé du musée Lambinet c'est
ré-ouvert après trois ans de travaux
donc j'étais avec Émilie maison neuve
qu'elle a directrice et le LM Candice le
conservateur du musée en Guinée entre
autres et elle nous a présenté donc les
nouvelles scénographies les nouvelles
pièces il y a des nouveaux objets qu'on
voyait pas qui sont mis en valeur
différemment il y a plein d'ateliers
aussi proposés j'ai l'impression c'est
la nouvelle mode ça des musiques qui
proposent plein d'ateliers
d'interactivité pour faire venir le
public c'est très bien et
et du coup ben voilà c'était avec elle
et le extrait peut-être de
l'autre on va regarder tout de suite
au musée Lambinet regardez
moi en mobilier en architecture plus
donc évidemment naturellement je me suis
plutôt intéressé à cette partie là mais
c'est surtout que ces œuvres-là étaient
plutôt des fervaloires autrefois et pas
vraiment des œuvres d'art à part entière
et on voulait les mettre vraiment en
avant donc là harpe de naderman là le
liquide de Marie-Antoinette est vraiment
exposé très en valeur dans le salon doré
elle a bénéficié surtout d'une
restauration son mécanisme fonctionne à
nouveau on peut en jouer on en a joué
lors de l'heure du vernissage la
réouverture en fait pour la réouverture
donc on est en train d'échanger les bons
plans sur le lanceur du Japon
on pourra profiter de cette gastronomie
japonaise street food et japonaise du
coup Vy P là qu'on retrouve bien sûr en
intégralité sur TV 78.com ça c'était au
musée Lambinet il y en a eu un autre
aussi tout récemment un autre qui était
ici même qui avec Bérengère Philippon
alors Bérengère Philippon elle est
maintenant
coach en nutrition elle s'intéresse
depuis quelques années elle est venue
hyper Calais elle a déjà fait trois
livres là les deux derniers viennent de
sortir sur une alimentation saine en
limitant l'indice glycémique voilà c'est
igba donc son premier livre c'était
recette igba recette salée donc là elle
s'est attaquée à recettes si j'ai barre
recette sucrée ce qui est un vrai
challenge parce que pas de sucre dans le
sud comme on fait elle a plein de de
moyens de petits trucs de russe et tout
pour pour qu'on y arrive et en même
temps c'est délicieux ce qu'elle propose
voilà et après elle a écrit un troisième
livre qui donne plus des clés c'est un
peu plus élargi au bien-être en général
alors comment comment se préparer
soi-même à changer éventuellement
d'alimentation être plus cool avoir une
psychologie positive oui genre
on peut mêler gastronomie aller un petit
peu diététique aussi derrière
le japonais c'est très léger il y a pas
de sucre aussi on le retrouve bien sûr
sur tv78.com juste pour revenir sur la
bachata ça m'intéresse beaucoup moi la
bachata au musée
on m'appelle le l'Italian lover dans
d'autres émissions voilà sur une autre
émission sur le si on parlait sport on
peut danser alors c'est ce qui est drôle
c'est qu'on danse au milieu des œuvres
finalement
incroyable c'est que vous dansez au
milieu des peintures qui qui en fait
sont les oeuvres de l'exposition
actuelle qui s'appelle femme encore
encore un autre lien donc femme ce sont
soit des sujets des femmes en sujet de
d'oeuvre de peinture soit des femmes
artistes qui ont qui ont exécuté ses
œuvres voilà et vous verrez des tableaux
certains ont été restaurés récemment
donc on l'avait pas vu depuis longtemps
d'autres ont été acquis aussi récemment
vous l'avez déjà dit tout à l'heure je
crois peut-être c'est pas bon c'est pas
grave voilà donc c'est vraiment original
et magnifique vous avez fait votre choix
gastronomie ou bachata faut les deux la
gastronomie naturellement
après tu vois les croquer un petit
ça nous a donné faim on va reparler de
gastronomie on aura une recette sur les
noix de Saint-Jacques c'est toujours un
peu difficile à cuisiner on aura
l'occasion dans reparler alors vous êtes
toujours si vous nous rejoignez bien sûr
sur TV 78 le 7 8 du lundi au jeudi c'est
votre émission qui fait le point sur les
actualités du jour les infos pratiques
aussi qui vous donne quelques idées de
sortie quelques bons plans également
alors si vous avez manqué le début de
l'émission pas de panique le rappelle
d'effet du jour avec Michaël et le minot
[Musique]
on commence les informations du jour par
cette tragédie survenue ce lundi en
Turquie et en Syrie un séisme d'une
magnitude 7,8 et des répliques ont
frappé ces deux pays au moins 5000
personnes sont mortes d'après les
dernières estimations dans les Yvelines
13 sapeurs-pompiers se rendent sur place
pour aider la population avec notamment
un médecin une infirmière et un chien de
recherche il rejoignent le détachement
USA spécialisé dans le sauvetage et le
débloiement la solidarité s'organise
également dans le département le Secours
populaire des Yvelines débloque une
première somme de 5000 euros et lance un
appel au don pour pousser à la
solidarité au soutien financier pour les
victimes de la catastrophe sur le plan
national 100 000 euros de fonds
d'urgence ont été débloqués pour les
familles pour donner les dons peuvent se
faire en ligne sur le site officiel du
Secours populaire après les journées du
19 et 31 janvier un nouveau mouvement de
greffe contre la réforme des retraites
était organisée ce mardi 7 février dans
toute la France selon les organisations
syndicales à mobilisation est toujours
aussi forte 17 buts CGT sont partis
aujourd'hui depuis les Yvelines certains
depuis trappes une mobilisation qui a eu
des conséquences sur les transports avec
intrins sur deux pour le RER A ou encore
un train sur 3 pour le RER BC des
chiffres similaires pour les trains sur
la ligne JLN et U du côté de
l'enseignement les chiffres sont en
baisse selon l'académie de Versailles
dans le premier degré on est passé de
41% de grévistes le 19 janvier à 11,43%
ce mardi 7 février au collège on recense
15,43% d'enseignants en grève et 9,42
dans les lycées l'association
protectrice des animaux la SPA lance une
application éphémère pour trouver son
futur compagnon pendant la période de la
Saint-Valentin le concept une fois
l'application téléchargée 5 questions
seront posées à l'internaute pour mieux
le connaître ainsi identifier l'animal
qui le correspond le mieux le refuge le
plus proche pour rencontrer des
pensionnaires lui sera ainsi suggérés
trois refuges sont ouverts dans les
Yvelines à Orgeval Hermeray et à plaisir
le Paris Saint-Germain qui déménagera
l'été prochain son à Poissy pourraient
également changer de stats selon nos
confrères de l'équipe le PSG à mandaté
un intermédiaire pour l'aider à trouver
un site pour la construction d'un
nouveau stade dans la région il
s'agirait de la société Legends une
entreprise qui a déjà travaillé dans le
football avec le Real Madrid et
Manchester City les propriétaires Cateri
voudraient toujours un stade une
capacité de 60 000 personnes il y a
quelques jours le député de la 12e
circonscription des Yvelines carlive
avait suggéré de construire un stade à
Poissy mais si et Neymar joueront-ils
dans les Yvelines réponse dans les
prochaines semaines
on ouvre une page culture dans le 7 8
[Musique]
et on accueille tout de suite par
visio-conférence Manon lepomme bonsoir
bonsoir connecter depuis la Belgique
votre pays vous êtes humoriste et vous
serez prochainement sur une scène
yvelinoise puisque vous serez en
spectacle sur la scène de la Royale
Factory à Versailles du jeudi 16 février
au samedi à 18 février dans votre one
woman show je vais beaucoup mieux merci
on va peut-être voir toutes les
informations s'afficher dans un instant
et c'est donc un nouveau one man one
woman show après je n'irai pas chez le
psy vous avez tout de même réussi le
tour de force Manon le pomme d'éviter à
250 000 spectateurs d'aller chez le psy
ça va ça va vraiment mieux aujourd'hui
Manon le pomme
et bien pour le savoir il faut venir
voir le spectacle c'est ça l'enjeu
évidemment bah oui le spectacle
s'appelle je vais beaucoup mieux merci
je crois que si vous venez voir le
spectacle vous allez très vite vous
rendre compte que je ne vais pas si bien
que ça ce n'est pas une suite beaucoup
de gens m'a demandé est-ce que c'est la
suite du précédent j'ai pas vu le
précédent pas du tout ce n'est pas du
tout une suite et c'est un spectacle ou
ben voilà j'ai 34 ans je fais un peu le
bilan est-ce que la petite Manon serait
fière de la grande Manon j'ai pas
d'enfant est-ce que j'en veux si j'en ai
comme est-ce que ça va se passer je
ressemble de plus en plus à mes parents
et ça c'est absolument terrible et donc
je cherche par tous les moyens de faire
le ressembler et ce qui est très
chouette avec ce spectacle c'est qu'il
est vraiment intergénérationnel il y a
plein de gens qui venaient avec leurs
ados par exemple sur les fait mourir de
rire eux en tant que parents ça les fait
rire les gens de mon âge bah ils se
retrouvent dans plein de questionnements
que je peux avoir sur le spectacle donc
du coup c'est un spectacle que je
conseille à tout le monde et puis alors
si vraiment vous avez pas d'idées voilà
Saint-Valentin moi je joue 16 17 18 donc
le 14 vous offrez maintenant le pomme et
puis on se rend compte le 16 le 17 ou 18
alors on va danser la bachata Véronique
dans les Yvelines et après on va voir
Manon le à Versailles le programme était
établi peut-être un petit passage aussi
par la street food japonaise pour faire
cette Saint-Valentin alors
malheureusement un extrait de votre one
woman show
regarde un peu les bégoniacs
elles sont en train de fleurir allez go
go go et comment est-ce que j'en suis
arrivé à me réjouir de regarder à faire
conclure
mais moi mon idole quand j'étais petit
c'était et la fois là vous la traversée
ce champ de mine en 10 personnages vous
souvenez de ça et moi je regardais ça je
dis attention attention
comme ça
alors vous l'avez dit vous ai raconté
votre vie de Néo trentenaire vous avez
33 ans alors il y a des anecdotes qui
sont tirées directement de vos
expériences personnelles pourquoi ce
thème de la trentaine pourquoi l'aborder
dans ce spectacle
parce que quand il était question
d'écrire ce nouveau spectacle donc j'ai
commencé à tourner en janvier 2022 et
moi ça me rend besoin d'un an de faire
un spectacle et en janvier 2021 je me
suis dit mais de quoi j'ai envie de
parler et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que j'avais plein de
questionnements que je me sentais très
très vieille alors que les gens me
disaient ma femme ah non t'es pas bien
et tu as 30 ans j'avais 32 ans en fait à
32 ans et puis et puis du coup de là est
parti en fait ben c'est vrai c'est un
constat très marrant entre deux ans de
sentir très très vieille et de là j'ai
réfléchi à plein de choses on a beaucoup
discuté avec le co-auteur et le metteur
en scène et puis ben ça a donné ça a
donné ce spectacle et en fait j'ai
repensé entre guillemets un peu toute ma
vie et qu'est-ce qu'elle dirait la
petite Manon comment elle me verrait et
puis de là on découlait mais plein de
sketchs et plein de thèmes en rapport
avec ça
on entend ça ça change réellement la vie
mais oui mais cette horrible mais vous
n'êtes pas encore concerné vous êtes
plus jeune moi je suis concerné
justement d'y aller il y a les questions
qui reviennent les enfants le mariage
etc on les pose un peu plus quand on
passe la trentaine ah oui et on vous
regarde autrement aussi quand vous pose
la question ah vous avez pas encore
d'enfants on a un peu inquiet pour vous
les gens sont plus inquiets que vous et
donc ça c'est assez interpellant et
d'avouer votre passion pour Lady Di
c'est une épreuve pour vous de la voix
dans ce spectacle
mais pas du tout j'ai une certaine
fierté et d'ailleurs ça me vient de ma
mère parce que ma mère était assez fan
aussi et donc ça aussi j'ai eu envie
d'en parler parce que parce que je suis
vraiment fan parce que je connais plein
de choses sur elle et les gens de ma
génération vous disent enfin comment ça
se fait que tu connais autant de choses
sur cette personne mais je dis mais
parce qu'elle est fascinante et donc
voilà j'en parle brièvement dans le
spectacle c'est un spectacle hyper
personnel franchement les 95% et je fais
exprès de dire 95 pour qu'on sache bien
d'où je viens 95% des choses sont vraies
25% des choses sont des histoires que
j'ai vécues et donc c'est aussi pour ça
que je crois que ça fonctionne c'est
parce que c'est un spectacle très
personnel en fait très très sincère et
donc on s'y reconnaît et vous le fait
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup d'autodérision
on peut dire que c'est un peu votre
marque de fabrique de parler de ce de
ces sujets justement avec des régions
oui bah c'est ce que les gens disent
c'est toujours très difficile évidemment
de demander un artiste mais comment est
votre spectacle quel est votre type
d'humour donc moi je reprends toujours
ce que des gens ont dit de moi parce que
les gens disent ben c'est que c'est très
généreux c'est très spontané parce que
c'est vrai que même si un texte qui est
écrit moi je fais toujours des
improvisations à chaque spectacle ce qui
rend les représentations très uniques et
ben voilà là je vais aller jouer en
région en région parisienne tout près de
Paris à Versailles en plus donc c'est
pas n'importe quoi et donc en tant que
belge bah évidemment on va faire des
petites références et comme je dis
toujours ben c'est pas parce que c'est
pas parce qu'on est belge qu'il faut se
de notre gueule ça fait 35 ans
que les Français se foutent de notre
gueule donc maintenant on se venge et
donc je ris de beaucoup de choses mais
je ris avant tout de moi-même c'est
l'essentiel et une petite question aussi
j'ai lu que vous vous rêviez petite
princesse j'ai lu ça quelque part et
vous avez été également enseignante il
me semble dans votre carré comment vous
êtes tombé dans l'humour finalement
qu'est-ce qui vous a fait atterrir dans
dans ce dans ce domaine là
alors sa princesse je ne savais pas vous
me la prenez
une star et qu'on dit j'ai lu dans une
interview et donc oui j'ai été prof j'ai
toujours voulu être comédienne en fait
depuis toute petite et puis mes parents
étaient pas très très chaud et donc j'ai
fait des études supérieures qui étaient
pas des études artistiques et puis j'ai
été enseignante j'adorais je me suis
beaucoup amusée honnêtement j'ai adoré
enseigner et puis je commençais à jouer
de plus en plus être plus en plus sur
scène et donc à un moment donné j'ai
lâché et maintenant ça fait 8 ans que je
suis comédienne à temps plein
le thème de la trentaine trentenaire en
plateau est-ce que c'est période de donc
vous gardez des souvenirs est-ce que ça
a été une étape dans votre vie Véronique
les gens de 30 ans en général enfin ont
du mal à être drôle et ils sont un peu
vieux dans leur tête parce que justement
ils ont tout ça qui retombe dessus et on
les comprend mais il faut se rassurer ce
qu'après on doit revient très vite jeune
et drôle voilà enfin maintenant elle est
drôle mais ça veut dire c'est c'est vrai
ah non je peux être pesant quelque part
alors moi je suis en plein dedans donc
du coup je le redeviendrai au le bientôt
donc
j'estime ça va bien pour moi voilà pour
les 30 ans écoutez ça va plutôt bien on
parle qu'on a 30 ans on parle de la
crise de la quarantaine alors avoir
bientôt pour l'instant ça va nickel
voilà moi j'arrive vers 40 ans donc mais
je me souvenir d'avoir une crise de la
fontaine ou quoi enfin j'avais hâte en
fait de d'avancer en âge voilà ce qui a
changé réellement pour Manon le pomme il
faudra aller à la Royal Factory du 16 au
18 février donc ce spectacle accueillant
qui ont tourné c'est quoi les projets
pour 2023 c'est de continuer cette
tournée Manon le pomme oui bah le but
c'est de de la tournée je vais un peu
partout en France je vais de plus en
plus en France donc ça c'est super je
retourne au Festival d'Avignon parce que
j'y étais en 2022 on y retourne en 2023
parce que ça a bien marché et donc on va
est-ce qu'on peut me souhaiter oui je
pense à ça une belle tournée avec plein
de dates et plein de publics donc du 16
au 18 février ce sera du côté de la
Royal Factory à Versailles info est
réservation vous avez vu le lien
s'afficher c'est directement sur le site
de la Royal Factory merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous maintenant le
pomme
merci c'est vraiment adorable de me
recevoir à très bientôt j'en profite de
vous avoir est-ce que vous êtes une fan
d'Harry Potter ou pas du tout et bien
non pas du tout mon compagnon très très
fort comme on dit chez nous mon
compagnon est fan il a lu les livres
certains plusieurs fois mais moi c'est
pas tellement mon pas tellement mon
kiffe j'ai un peu de mal avec avec
l'univers fantastique bon je vous libère
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
et ça me permet de tourner en plateau
est-ce que vous êtes fan d'Harry Potter
plutôt des livres plutôt des films moi
je suis un fan des deux univers très
livre voilà j'ai commencé avec les
livres est-ce que ou les avait lu est-ce
que vous avez vu les films et puis je
suis exactement comme Manon c'est à dire
que je que je suis pas du tout fan voilà
vous aimez bien est-ce qu'il y a plutôt
le film plutôt libre
non mais mes enfants aussi bon en tout
cas Harry Potter fête ses 25 ans cette
année c'est le premier livre le premier
tome qui est sorti en France en 1998
c'était il y a tout juste donc 25 ans
Harry Potter à l'école des sorciers pour
célébrer cet anniversaire la maison
d'édition Gallimard Jeunesse a organisée
le week-end dernier et lui Harry Potter
du côté de la librairie du pavé dans la
mare Élancourt on y a participé il y
avait des moldules et moldus c'est vous
savez c'est les noms sorciers voilà qui
étaient présents pour participer à une
chasse au trésor des énigmes ou encore
un quiz et parmi ces moldules il y avait
Mathilde le franco regardez
[Musique]
cap Noir cravate rayé lunettes rondes
les fans étaient au rendez-vous ce
samedi 4 février à l'occasion des nuits
Harry Potter c'est trop bien Harry
Potter on est des fans et bah le monde
il est magique le premier tome Harry
Potter à l'école des sorciers a soufflé
sa 25e bougie et pour fêter cet
événement Gallimard Jeunesse a mis à
contribution les librairies françaises
parmi les participants le pavé dans la
mare à Élancourt on a plusieurs
activités il va y avoir une chasse
l'espèce de chasse au trésor dans la
librairie des petits ateliers de
coloriage ou de coloriage ou de
fabrication et après sinon c'est des
petits jeux proposés par Gallimard des
mots mêlés ou autre sur l'unitou sur
l'univers d'Harry Potter
[Musique]
le principe du jeu c'est de retrouver
sur cette banderole qui a derrière vous
tous les personnages qui sont numérotés
ici et retrouver leur nom les et les
écrire sur sur la feuille
sur
linning sur de vivre Harry Potter
qu'on doit trouver comme celui-là là on
a cette émission
et au terme de cette soirée les moldion
ont été confrontés à un quiz les
gagnants pu remporter deux grands livres
pop-up du chemin de traverse le pavé
dans la mare étant lisse pour participer
à la grande finale du tournoi des
sorciers qui aura lieu en juin à Paris
[Musique]
ça me rappelle quelques souvenirs alors
on va poursuivre cette partie culturelle
avec une autre invité qui est avec nous
depuis le début de l'édition Mickaël
Diony alors on a commencé à en parler en
début d'émission à votre projet de votre
EP qui est sorti en 2022 c'était donc
son nom c'est 18 avant votre carrière
juste avant de venir ma musique ou vous
aviez fait des des études de psychologie
c'est ça
[Musique]
toujours fait partie de votre vie
exactement parce que je chante avec ma
grand-mère mon chez mon écoutait
beaucoup de musique mon papa écouter
beaucoup de musique donc j'ai toujours
voulu faire carrière dans la musique
mais il fallait faire des études et des
études sérieuses donc j'ai fait des
études en psycho et donc la musique est
toujours restée dans un coin de votre
tête oui mais j'en faisais parce que des
cours de piano je fais les cours de
guitare j'ai fait j'ai fait aussi
comédienne donc j'avais les cours de
théâtre aussi en parallèle et je me suis
dit à un moment donné il va bien falloir
que la musique elle sorte et donc je
fais mes études de psycho et puis et
puis la musique est voilà j'ai fait des
rencontres et puis et puis c'est parti
voilà donc il y a eu cette EP tout
dernièrement qui donc je le dis ça je le
disais s'appelle 18 et vous avez aussi
récemment remixé l'un de vos titres qui
s'appelle dépêche-toi d'aimer on va
écouter un extrait tout de suite
[Musique]
je t'aime mélancolie
flouteuse de thé noir et blanc
tu pleures place de l'Étoile
tout à l'heure de votre univers pop rock
là c'est un titre très électro vous
inspirez notamment de Madonna c'est ça
c'est l'une de vos sources
d'inspirations Madonna depuis mon plus
jeune âge j'ai beaucoup Madonna je me
prenais je dois dire voilà
mais sinon c'est prince quand j'ai fait
vraiment j'ai découvert prince je me
suis dit
voilà je vais faire je veux jouer de la
guitare je vais être sur scène c'est
vraiment la scène qui m'a tirait et nous
aussi pourquoi je j'ai fait un peu
comédienne aussi et donc non c'est plus
prints qui m'inspire sa folie
et puis son mélange des gens alors ça ça
m'intéresse
on me met dans dans pop rock le rock
Louise s'exprime vraiment ce que ce que
j'écris parce que il y a du dynamisme il
y a la force etc mais mais oui j'aime
ces mélanges et ce remix oui il est
sorti pour aussi pour pour changer un
petit peu j'aime bien l'électro c'était
pour donner une autre dynamique mais
sinon c'est du rock oui
vous avez d'autres styles ça me va bien
ouais très bien j'adore
avec la bachata
alors dans les thématiques vous abordez
il y a notamment la thématique de
l'amour qui revient souvent pourquoi
c'est une thématique qui qui fait sens
pour vous qui vous touche que vous aimez
traiter dans votre travail ça parle à
tout le monde et c'est tellement vague
si vous voulez donc je dirais plutôt que
l'amour le sentiment voilà tout ce qui
tout ce qui nous exprime tout ce qui
nous inspire tout ce qu'on ressent donc
plutôt le sentiment que l'amour au sens
vraiment large le sentiment
la mélancolie également l'a dit donc la
musique a toujours fait partie de notre
vie même si finalement vous y êtes
revenu par par la force des choses et
était notamment directrice artistique
aux côtés d'un d'un photographe c'est ça
qui s'appelle Franck Strom exactement
qui est qui a photographié tout le monde
et qui était aussi reporter de guerre et
donc j'étais sa directrice artistique
jusqu'à même encore maintenant ça vous a
enrichi maintenant même dans le
parce que j'ai rencontré le bassiste de
Jean des plaint qui faisait partie des
Rita Mitsouko et donc j'ai commencé à
travailler avec lui un premier single
qui est sorti
avant le P et puis après j'ai fait
d'autres rencontres et puis j'ai
travaillé le P voilà alors dans les
inspirations également il y a Alain
Bashung Christophe encore muse
finalement c'est beaucoup de figures
masculine et placebo également c'est
beaucoup de figures masculines le rock
on peut pas faire de d'Europe quand on
est une femme
mais j'aime cette ambiguïté en fait
entre une fille voilà qui est assez
féminine ou qui a des allures très
féminines et qui peut faire du rock
justement avec
[Musique]
beaucoup de
comment dire
[Musique]
de plein de choix d'énergie
c'est pas le mot que cherchait
les projets pour la suite c'est quoi les
projets je continue donc la promo la
suite c'est évidemment la scène donc
voilà ça ça continue et on peut
retrouver votre actualité sur vos
réseaux sociaux
toutes les plateformes et donc bah je
souhaite à tout le monde une bonne
écoute la page Instagram pour retrouver
votre actualité mais le fait 18 est
disponible sur toutes les plateformes
bien sûr musicale merci d'être venu en
parler en plateau c'est bientôt l'heure
de passer à table on va regarder tout de
suite une idée de recette
[Musique]
vous aviez une question mais on a alors
juste avant de passer à autre chose
pourquoi 18 18 alors déjà je suis né en
18 donc voilà ça me représente et 18
pour moi est un chiffre symbolique car
tout au long de ma vie il y a énormément
de 18 et je retrouve à chaque fois ce 18
qui me parle c'est mon chiffre
voilà on match différents univers on
pose des questions mais effectivement
c'était une très bonne question merci
merci Véronique une toute autre question
on passe à un tout autre genre une
recette de cuisine moi je disais en
début d'édition mais quand même du mal à
cuisiner les noix de Saint-Jacques c'est
difficile d'obtenir la bonne texture la
bonne cuisson ce que vous avez aussi
cette difficulté ce que vous en êtes
déjà cuisiné bien sûr mais après oui
c'est subtil donc faut pas les écraser
il faut faire attention avec la
compagnement et comme vous dites la
cuisson c'est
très délicat c'est très délicat alors si
vous posez des questions autour de la
cuisson des noix de Saint-Jacques pas de
panique notre astuce du chef du jour est
consacrée justement aux noix de
Saint-Jacques et c'est Armindo Machado
qui vous donne ses conseils pour réussir
la recette une recette à la provençale à
une recette très précise il est chef
cuisiniers de l'Auberge du Manet à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux on regarde tout
de suite ça recette
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Armindo machadou je
suis chef de cuisine à l'auberge du
Manet à Montigny-le-Bretonneux je vais
vous présenter une recette de
Saint-Jacques poêlées au pesto de
tomates confites que nous avons à la
carte en ce moment
sel poivre
[Musique]
pour colorer la table
faire attention de pas trop les cuire
[Musique]
et déposer
et un petit peu de pesto au basilic
[Musique]
voilà c'est comme ça qu'on la serre tout
simplement
voilà alors la petite astuce pour la
cuisson des Saint-Jacques évidemment
c'est de ne surtout pas trop les cuire
sinon ça devient très vite
philanthruque caoutchouteux donc il faut
cuire à feu doux et terminer la cuisson
au beurre en arrosant voilà bon appétit
[Musique]
dit comme ça ça paraît simple
j'ai tout faux mais je le saurai c'est
plus important merci à Armindo macho
pour sa recette des noix de
Saint-Jacques à la provençale c'est
bientôt la fin de cette émission mais
avant on va jeter un dernier coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
et c'est une journée de mercredi
similaire à celle d'aujourd'hui du froid
mais aussi du soleil le matin il fera
moins de degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie à
Rambouillet - 1 degré à Houdan et
Versailles dans l'après-midi même
condition avec un thermomètre qui grimpe
quelque peu compter 6 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 5 degrés sur le reste
du département et ce mercredi 8 février
c'est la sainte Jacqueline donc on
pourra tester sa recette de
Saint-Jacques noix de Saint-Jacques avec
Jacqueline je sais pas si je l'assume
cette blague totalement ça va être
l'heure de rendre l'antenne merci de
nous avoir suivi dans cette émission
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 et demain vous
vous retrouverez pour une nouvelle
édition à la présentation Mathilde
Franco belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]